oh boy lots to unpack
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by cerebral
and we'll be reviewing
lifestyle and wellness content creator
hannah adkins
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor cerebral
so i've been very open about my
struggles with anxiety
insomnia and mental health and
considering that 50
of the general population has a mental
health condition
i know that i'm not alone so i
acknowledge that i have been
super privileged to have been able to
access therapists
and doctors and other supporters when i
need them
but i know how many of you messaged me
to tell me that
there are just too many financial time
and stigma related barriers
to getting the help that you need so i
was really excited when i heard about
cerebral
so cerebral is a mental health
subscription that provides clients with
ongoing
comprehensive access to online care and
medication management
for anxiety depression and insomnia for
a flat monthly rate
this is really your one stop shop for
all things mental health care
it's super convenient because they
operate on your schedule
where you can work out your calls or
video visits in
whenever it works for you and it's way
more affordable than typical therapy
they actually have three different plans
depending on your needs
so if this sounds like it may be helpful
for you or somebody that you care
about click the link down in the
description to get started with cerebral
and access quality mental health
treatment today
for as low as 30 for your first month
also feel free to pause the screen or
check out my description for a quick
disclaimer
including a trigger warning for those
with past or current experiences with
disordered eating
as always i'm talking nutrition calories
macros etc so
feel free to skip this video if it does
not feel supportive to your journey
now just a quick recap on the subject of
our video before we dive
in hannah is a uk based health fitness
and
lifestyle influencer and a lot of you
requested that i review her viral video
titled
how i lost fat toned up and changed
my mindset five tips so today we're
going to be discussing
my opinions on the tips that she gives
in this video
along with some of the other content
that i found on her various social
platforms
all right let's take a look at some of
her weight loss tips
there is more in your food than carbs
fat and protein aka
your macros i can't tell you how
simplistic
and problematic that approach is you
could eat a diet of
almost entirely processed foods and
still fulfill your
macro nutrient goals but that is so
far from a healthy holistic balanced
approach okay so i don't disagree with
hannah here
i have said this multiple times that i
think one of the dangers of the
if it fits your macros approach is that
it can really oversimplify eating
to like a calculation that we don't
actually have a whole lot of good
evidence to support
we may have general macronutrient ranges
or food group recommendations
a la the food guide that are associated
with good improved health
but it's also easy to cheat the system
to choose nutrient poor foods and i
would say fiber and micronutrients
are arguably even more important than
macros in the quest for good health and
satiety
so just as an example if we were to
compare a big mac from mcdonald's with
a whole wheat turkey veggie sandwich
served with whole wheat crackers
cheese and carrots we're looking at
about the same amount of calories and
carbs
but a much more satiating and nutrients
dense
meal when you go with the sandwich
option
so while i don't really appreciate her
over generalization and demonizing of
the words processed foods
which i'm going to circle back on soon
we are definitely in agreement on
her criticism of exclusive macro
counting
is please educate yourself on the topic
of nutrition and i don't mean go and
what's your favorite influences
q a i'm not claiming to be an expert i'm
not an expert
read books by experts listen to podcasts
watch ted talks
okay lots to unpack here
first of all i just have to say right
off the bat that
one of my least favorite lines in the
wellness community is
do your research it's used a lot
in anti-science communities as like a
fear-mongering tactic
and that often makes people often women
often mothers feel that they're putting
their family in danger for
not seeking out alternative facts or
truths
that oppose mainstream science or health
officials recommendations
it can be really problematic it also
wrongly assumes that the lay person is
capable of
critically evaluating research or
knowing who is in fact
a credible source of information which
we actually know most people are just
not that's not me trying to be holier
than now i'm just saying that
yeah science is complicated stuff so the
source of that research
is probably even more important than the
research itself
now i was excited to hear hannah
recommend that we listen to actual
experts about nutrition and not just
follow what like our favorite
influencers are saying
but as i alluded to just a minute ago
what's missing here
are some actionable tips on how to find
said experts and that's kind of
important since
there are a lot of folks on the internet
who claim to be experts or
professionals who are in fact not
evidence-based
case in point some of the experts on
hannah's go-to list so i want to just
kind of go through them
really super quickly here now her first
suggestion is dr michael greger who is
an influential player
in the plant-based community as the
best-selling author of
how not to die and a doctor who is
heavily
involved in pro-vegan advocacy efforts
he's a physician and obviously there's
credibility there
and i do have faith that doctors even
though
most are not really trained to know much
about nutrition at all
should at least be fully capable of
interpreting research and
keeping up to date with the evidence in
the field
so i do think that most doctors
including gregor
are credible sources for health
information
and from what i've seen myself gregor's
content and
recommendations are generally factually
sound however no one is without bias
and gregor has been criticized for
cherry-picking the data that he presents
when discussing the risks of animal
product consumption
he also obviously has a financial agenda
to do this since
he himself has a pro-vegan book that
he's trying to sell
so again i'm generally aligned with this
recommendation
but i just want to point out that doctor
doesn't always mean trustworthy unbiased
nutrition expert now hannah's next
recommendation is
julia enders who's a german scientist
and phd student
who studies microbiology and also very
publicly discusses the importance of
gut health she honestly doesn't have a
huge
presence which is probably a good thing
and seeing as i didn't find any
big problematic red flags i would say
it's probably a pretty safe bet but of
course if you know something that i
don't know
please send i'm happy to be proven wrong
now finally deliciously ella is another
one of her favorites
who's a very well-known plant-based
cookbook author and internet personality
and while i love ella's recipes and
honestly i've used a ton of them
in my own kitchen for some plant-based
inspiration
i do want to point out that she doesn't
have any qualifications in the field of
nutrition
and this is kind of at odds with
hannah's advice to
listen to the experts honestly this to
me just further solidifies
how difficult it often is for most
people to discern
a credible source from a non-credible
source
even when they think they're being super
mindful of this
so if you're curious here are some tips
for determining
whether or not a piece of information or
source of information
is credible first of all you want to
look for authors who are willing to
provide
contradicting evidence or at least to
acknowledge
when the research in the field is young
or of poor quality
i also always look for articles that
cite their sources
and you'll want to look for actual
published peer-review research as
sources
not just blogs quoting blogs in an echo
chamber
obviously you want to look for articles
written by experts in the field
so qualifications like md phd
or rd is a good place to start and
finally
be weary of articles that funnel you
into
a sales portal to buy a very specific
product
that supports the stamps when the
sponsorship or financial incentive
isn't disclosed anyways that was a lot
but let's move on but i cannot stress
enough
how much there is not a
one-size-fits-all
approach to exercise you don't need to
be doing hit
five times a week you can wake up in the
morning and think what i feel like today
some days that might be a walk some days
that might be super high intensity
training
some days it might be gentle yoga as
long as you are
keeping your body moving most days of
the week
you're not gonna you're not gonna go
wrong okay so hannah is suggesting
that in the past she would do workouts
that she actually really
hated in order to just like take off the
box of working out
but it ended up just making her dread
going to the gym
and moving her body she then suggests
that by
shifting her mindset around exercise to
an act of
self love and pleasure she was actually
able to see better results and this is
absolutely how i feel about exercise as
well
all movement is good movement and as i
discuss in detail in my video on joyful
movement here
i am adamant that we really need to get
out of the mentality that
hey if i didn't sweat hard enough or get
out of breath
or keep my heart rate in the fat burning
zone
then i didn't do anything today no
you have to think about the long game
fitness and nutrition are both long
games
if you go too hard and too fast and you
burn out
you're never going to improve your
health long term
and research suggests that consistency
is really the key with any health
promoting habit
so i do recommend experimenting to find
something that you actually enjoy
and trying to incorporate it at a pace
that feels sustainable to you
i want to talk about substitutes i
personally
don't buy anything that's labeled low
fat lights
diet the chemicals that they have added
into that food
so that it still tastes good without the
sugar or without the fat
are doing you so much more harm than the
sugar or the fat
okay so lots to say about this
so for the most part i am in agreement
that
when you swap out a food that you love
for a diet version
you often end up eating around your
craving
on what i like to call the satisfaction
hunt more time than not
this results in overeating i mean i talk
about it all the time
you want the oreo so you eat the fruit
salad then the rice cakes and the
fat-free
pudding then the granola bar and then
you binge on a whole box
of oreos but had you just allowed
yourself a mindful portion of the cookie
that you really craved
you probably would end up taking in a
lot fewer calories
and could just kind of move on with the
rest of your life
without investing so much time and
mental energy
on the hunt now specific to hannah's
discussion on
light aka low fat or low sugar versions
of regular foods
it is true that most of the time food
manufacturers have to replace a
desirable substance that they're taking
out
with something else so sometimes this
makes the food
actually less satisfying because it just
doesn't taste as good and
other times it also makes it less
physically satiating as well so consider
for a second
light or lower fat peanut butter as an
example
when we take out some of that fat we
need to replace it
with sugar and or salt the calories
actually are hardly impacted
but now we've got a spread that doesn't
even keep us
as full for as long and also doesn't
taste as good
so in those cases i definitely say
go with the real deal or at least go
with
whatever feels more delicious and
satisfying to you
but it's also worth just flagging that
hannah's rationale for this is not so
much about the satisfaction
or satiety factors but that there are
apparently
chemicals added into these diet foods
that are
far worse than actual sugar or fat
so yeah let's
unpack
[Music]
now i get that by chemicals hannah
probably means
additives and preservatives which is not
untrue
so a lot of lower fat products need
extra
stabilizers or gums added to them to
give them the same stability
and mouth feel that we would enjoy from
actual fat
but it's important to note that the word
chemicals
sounds way scarier than it actually is
and food ingredient fear-mongering is
literally one of my biggest
pet peeves of life folks
everything we eat is made out of
chemicals
so for example did you know that the
chemical
cold calciferol is found lurking in a
wide range of packaged processed foods
sounds pretty scary right well this
chemical is actually just vitamin d3
and yeah that fortification is helping a
lot of us
get our daily fix without the risk of
skin cancer from
excess sun exposure my point here is
just to say that demonizing the word
chemicals
is counterproductive to helping people
feel at ease
with making less diety food choices in
their day
this is what happens when we trade diet
culture with wellness culture
which is arguably even more pervasive
and problematic
but anyways that is a ted talk for
another day
let's see what else she has to say let
me tell you about my kind of substitutes
lentil pasta pea pasta chickpea pasta
rye bread instead of white bread dark
chocolate
they're my kind of substitutes the
nutritional value and the micronutrients
in those substitutes
are far better than in the kind of more
processed alternatives
okay so hannah says she likes to replace
some of her favorite food choices
with more nutrient-dense swaps like
treating
in a bean based pasta for white pasta
whole grain bread for white bread
and a dark chocolate for milk chocolate
and these choices
sound great to me as long as they are
enjoyable to her
but how healthy these healthy swaps
are ultimately comes down to intention
to me
if you're choosing dark chocolate
because it feels good to you
amazing you go get that dark chocolate
queen
i say enjoy the physical and emotional
satisfaction
that you get from making that choice and
in hannah's case
it does sound like she still enjoys a
good dark chocolate
or bean based pasta and is also
motivated by the added nutrition in
these which i think is great
i also choose chickpea pasta all the
time because
i love the added fiber and protein on
board to really keep me
and my kiddos satisfied and to me
it's just a really easy swap to make
most of the time
that doesn't trigger scarcity mentality
to me
but if you're choosing it out of food
fear for the
fake ingredients or chemicals in like a
dairy milk bar
then i do think that you risk diet
rebellion and
potentially a binge later on take more
time
to try and learn new recipes eating
home-cooked food
is always going to be the best option if
you're looking to manage your weight in
some way when you eat out
that you have no idea what they've added
into that food so unless you're ordering
from somewhere that's like an organic
it really is better to make your own
food at home learning how to cook
wholesome nutritious food is honestly so
key okay so obviously i'm a big believer
in home cooking so
i do love this tip i also love that
hannah is trying to encourage folks who
maybe don't have the best track record
or history with cooking
that it's just never too late to learn
amen to that and yes research does show
that
restaurant food tends to be higher in
calories fat saturated fat and salt
when compared with home-cooked food
there's really no
denying that but i think it's really
important that we don't stress ourselves
out about this
and let it interfere with our enjoyment
of special social experiences
fearing food that you don't prepare
yourself is one of the big
red flags of orthorexia so i do think
that improving our relationship with
food
requires tolerating some uncertainty
around what is in our food or how it's
being prepared
but i do want to comment on her
suggestion that this isn't really a
concern
as long as the restaurant is an organic
whole foods place
um you do know that organic restaurants
use a lot of sugar salt and fat too
right
and that organic maple syrup has just as
many calories
and as much sugar as non-organic white
sugar right
organic also doesn't necessarily mean
healthier
i mean this is a big conversation and i
have touched on it before in my
sorella more video right here but unless
your concern is specifically
things like genetically modified oils
there's
probably not a huge difference in the
ingredients
used or the nutrition content of the
meals
from an organic versus a non-organic
restaurant
so yes i don't disagree that we should
aim to cook the majority of our meals
ourselves at home
especially if calories are a concern
because we know that like
cooking at home allows us to customize
our meals to our diet needs
to focus on more appropriate portions
for us to limit
waste and to save money which are
all valid things in my books but my take
home here is that
organics shouldn't get like a free pass
and when you do go out to enjoy a meal
enjoy it enjoy the food enjoy the
experience
stressing over what's hidden in the food
that is
bad for your health is what is actually
bad for your health
please don't underestimate how important
shifting your
mindset and your mental well-being is
i've said this before in another video
but you cannot hate
yourself healthy okay so i love the
quote you cannot
hate yourself healthy so remember what i
said earlier
health and wellness is all about the
long game
it's really about figuring out which
health promoting behaviors
you can do for the rest of your life
without making yourself
unhappy and science really does echo
this sentiment
so research has found that
non-stigmatizing more supportive
techniques
are preferred and are more successful
for promoting healthy behaviors
over a typical tough love approach
so yeah i say give yourself
some grace and patience is please listen
to your body
you shouldn't try to outsmart trick or
ignore your body
if you're hungry please eat that is your
body telling you that you need
fuel if every single time you eat a meal
you're getting like really
painful bloating rather than punishing
yourself please see an expert
and get their opinion okay so this is
really good advice that i definitely
agree with
and you know i say it a lot listen
to your body but i will say that as i
grow in this
body neutrality intuitive eating space i
also want to acknowledge that
i know it can be really overly
simplistic as well
and also probably not very helpful for a
lot of folks
who've been trapped in diet culture and
restriction for so long
i also appreciate that a lot of people
may just need more guidance and more
structure
and saying just listen to your body
might feel
really stressful or even impossible for
some folks
some people may not know what feels good
to their body
after just like listening to external
cues for just so long in their life
so if you're just getting started on
listening to your body
but maybe you don't feel hunger or you
don't feel hunger until it's like an
intense
give me all the food experience consider
eating
like a small meal every few hours to
just encourage those cues to return
and i also agree that if you're
experiencing digestive symptoms
after every meal or snack please
definitely speak to a doctor before
like self-diagnosing or cutting out a
bunch of foods
this often can lead to food fears
and also can potentially create
digestive symptoms
thanks to the intense interaction
between our gut and brain
and if you hop right into eliminations
without speaking to a professional
first it also can make it more difficult
to rule out
diseases like celiac for example since
you need to actually be eating things
like gluten to properly
test for the condition anyways i am glad
to hear that hannah has made some
changes to help improve her relationship
with her body
and herself and food and to start to
shed some
of her diet culture beliefs of her past
but before i close off
i do want to quickly touch on some other
comments and messages that i came across
while perusing her youtube and social
media channels
now according to an instagram q a on her
page hannah went fully plant-based in
january 2020 for ethical reasons at
first
but she soon found that it also made it
easier
for her to maintain her weight loss
because she likes to eat
big portions and this does make sense
seeing as plant-based foods are
naturally typically
higher in fiber and usually less
calorically dense
compared to animal based products so for
example
putting together a 400 calorie salad of
veggies and chickpeas
is going to yield a significantly larger
portion than
400 calories of steak with cheese but
ultimately this comes down to satiety
and satisfaction
on a caloric deficit i could think of a
lot of calorically dense foods that are
also vegan
like fries are vegan candies vegan there
are vegan cookies and burgers and ice
creams and cakes and pizza etc
so vegan doesn't necessarily mean locale
or volume dense and on the flip side
being an omnivore doesn't mean you can't
enjoy
big portions of salad or fruit or high
fiber whole grains or beans
or other higher volume lower calorie
foods
again the key is sustainability
and if giving yourself a rule that you
can't eat your beloved cheese
triggers a scarcity mentality that leads
you to
plow through a pint of oat milk ice
cream every single night
you're probably not going to lose weight
but if you
naturally enjoy choosing those higher
volume higher fiber
plant-based foods then of course it's
going to be easier for you to sustain
and maintain and therefore potentially
to lose weight
and keep it off now i also watched a
quick what in a day video from hannah's
channel
just to get a sense of how her advice
plays out in her daily diet in real life
and to summarize hannah's day of eating
is
very similar to what she describes so
she has a vegan bacon sandwich for
breakfast
avocado toast for lunch and a portion of
chickpea pasta with veggies for dinner
she also does a little haul of all of
her favorite vegan snack foods which
all look totally delicious so it is
refreshing to see someone eat
like a whole foods plant-based diet with
some more convenience foods
mixed in which i just find feels more
sustainable
and accessible to most people watching
from home
and while i did find her calories and
protein intake was maybe a little bit
lower than where
i would personally want them i get that
she is on a weight management journey
and as such
she might just be used to eating in a
more significant deficit
so in conclusion i do agree with a lot
of hannah's sentiments in her viral
weight loss video particularly the
take-home message
to really appreciate and listen to your
body and practice
self-love i do think it's worth doing a
little bit more soul-searching on her
sentiments around chemicals
and so the more moralizing language that
i heard here
and also maybe a little research herself
on the experts that she chooses to trust
but i mean we're all learning what feels
best to our body
so it's possible that with a little bit
more experimentation and
data collection that she may just find a
place that
better supports her mental and physical
health
and ultimately i do believe that her
sentiments are coming from a really good
place
and that her channel feels relatively
benign in the context of
the pseudoscience wellness youtube
community
so i do wish her lots of luck and
support on the rest of her journey
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today folks thank you again
to cerebral for sponsoring this video if
you liked it be sure to give it that
thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like seeing your view next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye and for more great videos like this
check out the links right here